quel moment vinci et les actionnaires
vont s'arrêter de nous engouffrer et
nous allons nous faire croire qu'il n'ya
pas d'argent magique
y'a que ça la crise de covin l'a montré
l'argent magique qui en a par dessus la
tête tu voudrais que la direction
reprennent un peu contact avec l'humain
la paix et qu'elles sortent un peu de
ces bilans financiers pour s'intéresser
à ce que vivent les salariés
[Musique]
la plupart des salariés soient engagées
produits sur des charges financières une
vie de famille donc pour la plupart ceux
qui travaillent à roissy on travaille et
habite beaucoup au nord de voici ceux
d'orly habite au sud orly et donc se
déplacer comme ça c'est c'est quasiment
impossible en ile de france
[Musique]